hello everyone i'm lana welcome to my
channel where today we are trying out
saints row 2022 obviously
uh for the first time probably gonna go
with
default difficulty here
uh the game comes out tomorrow at the
time of embargo and we're just gonna
play through probably the first hour now
i have not played it before this this
will be my fresh impressions and
i wouldn't say i'm excited about this
game um there have been a lot of
installments to the sainsbury franchise
that i have really loved
a little bit hit and miss for me so
more than anything i would say that i'm
curious
the marketing for this has been like
okay like i i a lot of people hated it i
didn't love it but i didn't hate it
either i was like i just don't really
know
what you're going for
and maybe it's zoomers
but uh i guess we'll see
the
audio's
very strange right now
maybe i just had it too low
you sure you're at the right party
this is a celebration for the saints is
it not
business with marshall is less lucrative
than it used to be
i was hoping your bosses would be
interested in it does look very outdated
i will say that
[Music]
like the
the face is very cartoony which is
obviously a style choice but i would say
that this looks like a
i don't know
a different generation of video game
[Music]
look i i know that we don't have the
best history
but i was thinking
hoping really
that we could work something out
character creation i should make myself
smaller also my hair is
a mess
um okay
that's gonna be
my default
hmm
interesting
[Music]
wow
okay
uh build i'd want to go like this like
but not too much like a
sort of like a here
i won't take too long doing this i
promise
skin tint oh i see they do have really
good character creators muscle
definition you know too much but yeah
veins
wow
glossiness
wow
body scars
cat scratches oh that looks cool yeah
you can have those
that's cool
skin details
it's just entirely vitiligo
um
[Music]
okay
back
hair
i always make a very similar character
and it's gotta be
usually it's like a back ponytail type
thing that's a little bit too feminine
though
like a masculine yeah that can work
i gotta be white
oh there's three colors in it
white and daca white
cool
okay facial has usually stubble
that one kind of works
stubble there we go
that's fine
eyebrows
it is a really cool character creator
because um
don't look that straight when i like it
um
you can really just throw anything on
anyone which is awesome
basic lashes seems fine
i would have liked to have changed your
eye color that's probably in face
oh boy this is a lot
i'm fine with the face for the most part
[Music]
what does that do
i see
width
and i want it to be like longer
yeah
seems good
uh cheeks the jaws gotta be nuts
[Music]
i don't know how you'd measure any of
these things
just back to zero please okay let's go
width
i don't know what off this [ __ ] is dude
it's fine you look you look great you
look great dude
i just want to change your eye color
is that in head eyes
color there we go and i always like a
yellow
one that's not too intense
or a purple
i'm gonna go with the yellow
there we go
beautiful
tattoos
head face
[Music]
yeah okay
i can't select them oh because that
costs money maybe i'm not sure what we
can figure that out later i need to
stretch my muscles out you've joined
something big here
i think i'm ready for some action this
town is house for the taking
you're definitely one of us mate what
are many money today
don't make a lady wait now
when can you start
going
on
oh then he's a cowboy something about no
rush by the way take your time this
is going on here today i hate what all
of them are saying and i think that's
making me dislike the voice like the
fact that this one was like what a
beautiful day to be me this is a vibe
you are in for a world of pain
when can you start
that seems like the most normal
yeah i've always got this
okay
sure yeah
cool
all right let's go
yeah it'll do for now
good enough i don't want to spend too
long on it i did it under 10 minutes i'm
a god
antonio glad you came to your senses hey
i'm kind of having a party right now but
oh no i hate me oh no
[Laughter]
that's a shame
i think i'm a douchebag we got a party
going on so i'm gonna keep this one
short and sweet
[ __ ] the panteros [ __ ] the idols [ __ ]
marshall the saints are here to stay
baby
so if you know how to shoot a gun or if
you're broke and want to learn how swing
by the church we'll be waiting for you
it really feels like that character
should be somebody else
that i get why i'm talking to them
but it feels like they should be
like
i guess you play as the president in
previous games
cool transition work there
why
i like this this is cool i'm interested
that was very very nice transition
am i being buried alive
it's what he deserves he's a douchebag
maybe this will
humble him a bit
oh on the same night
hmm
i didn't expect that so much
a lot of the saints row games have had
like
barry nuts creative
it wasn't gameplay getting here your
journey began with one of the most
unforgiving job interviews we could
devise
but you did more than just service but
also so far what is this game
you excel
what's going on prove that you were
marshall material but don't take my word
for it hear it from the man himself
hello i'm atticus marshall and i wanted
to personally welcome you to the
marshall fact he saw the heart here at
mdi we don't just make a profit
we make the world a better place
very good
so how do we do that
with a little tlc
technologically advanced weapons loose
morals and a cop i don't think he looks
old you know the comment i made earlier
about it looking outdated this guy
doesn't maybe it was just the the
lighting why are you watching that now
it's the orientation video i know what
it is why are you watching it now well i
mean we're about to be shot at so i
figured it couldn't hurt to brush up on
our health care package if you weren't
paying attention to the briefing i don't
think you'll live long enough for your
copay to matter so i should be reviewing
the life insurance policy you know our
job interview has a 5 mortality rate
statistically the odds were low that you
would die before we hired you but i
allowed myself to be an optimist your
parents should have treated you better
yours should have treated you worse
all right ladies and gentlemen okay
contrary to your colleague's demeanor
this is no laughing matter the nawali
already took out one team that was sent
to bring him in and i want as many of us
going home as possible so stick to the
plan work together and let's grab that
son of a [ __ ] and send him to the
frontier okay
[Applause]
let's get paid
alpha team go first day on the job [ __ ]
up
newbie ketchup right let's kick some
holy [ __ ] turrets take cover
oh boy all right this is the fun silly
gameplay in tribute
there's always something
okay i see what we're in for
jesus christ
he's looking
pretty
um
glitchy i will say i think
does it look like there's a couple
systems
hoping i could crouch but the buttons i
expected did not work
i'm not exactly taking a coffee break
here
it like feels
are these good guys yeah quote unquote
fun like it's it's floaty and like airy
like sort of in the way that um the
superhero one was for cool
cover feels fun
it feels like it'll be fun to play
like it's not very grounded but in a way
that i think is
fitted
i guess there's a better way to express
what i'm trying to say there
it does feel uh already
pretty glitchy though
there was that animation with the ship
moving and i just got caught on a piece
of wood
you guys [ __ ] with the wrong
multinational private military
corporation great
hey this may be a weird time to ask but
do we get hazard pay you get a
performance bonus for outstanding work
if you survive
you got it it's a very aggressive auto
aim
that's okay
and i guess also everyone else i'm
shooting with is useless is he taking
any damage
very little
cool that was easy
i would like to pick up a shotgun can i
do that from you
can't pick up their weapons strange
bailey hold up marshall play the field
can you imagine you for a dead option
played like this wait what
oh
my bad i was not even paying attention
to it to be honest i was just scoping
out the video game i deserved that
i was paying so little attention to the
apc health bar because i was like the
game my bad my bad
huh
it's an interesting choice that um
focusing on the explosives is just hit
triangle so you'll auto target them i
guess
i guess that's the game knowing what it
is it knows that it's it's chaotic it's
not about like combat finesse or
whatever
who knows why people are playing it
bailey hold up marshall play the field
yes ma'am
[ __ ]
take the turret i got it i'm good with
these
the setting is cool too
stuff i like going on here
nice
oh
this um
is very basic
all right
take it out before it cuts down
what can i get boss man not so funny
when you're taking fire huh
you all right bailey bailey get your
foot off the gas
whoa whoa oh [ __ ]
okay
it's
a little bit ridiculous but okay
what just happened
gwen gwen can you hear me anybody
if you say so what the [ __ ] was that why
would that have happened
i love that that's just like a team in
the tutorial being like and then they
end up in a cave okay how do they get to
the the cave the mine shop how do they
end up there
um
the car
uh just into the car and then it flips
and rocks
it's she's really just like
all right
uh take down an enemy and regain health
in combat cool
still don't know if i can crouch though
you know what i'm saying eliminate your
intruder
uh for reference everybody because i
didn't mention it uh earlier sorry i am
playing on pc
what's the percentage for everyone
[Music]
so i'm working for marshall right now
um i guess i leave marshall
certainly still end up in a ditch
somehow
which is interesting enough
okay
hey bud didn't see that finally end of
the tunnel
okay
gwen hello do you read me no you're
still alive yeah i hear that a lot the
nawali's holds up in the saloon up ahead
rendezvous with the rest of us i keep
thinking they're saying diwali
i gave you an order it's on the way
besides we don't want them coming up
behind us later fine but next time i
give an order the only words i want to
hear are yes and ma'am got that uh yes
ma'am
i keep wanting to look at stuff but now
i'm worried the mission will fail this
is um
uh i like the way this environment has
been crafted like this is this is pretty
cool level design not in terms of the
combat in terms of combat it's very like
run through hallways and shoot type
vibes but um
it's just a very interesting setting i
like the way things are laid out
and funnels into open areas into funnels
is yeah
i think this is uh
cool but also almost definitely not
indicative of the
full game
i would think
and i hope it's not this easy
it feels good to make an honest living
gotta earn that performance bonus i need
to take down on somebody
where y'all at
i wonder if you can fail that
not sure
yes you [ __ ] are just working stiffs
oh i can't do oh okay the percentage is
the countdown for
the the takedown maybe the c4 should
take out that barricade
okay
well i don't have any
get a c4 satchel charge
convenient very convenient
okay
we'll be over here
it's a cool setting glad you could join
us thank you thanks for having me
appreciate it
once we hit the saloon you flank left
while the rest of us hold the center
blank but i can
okay yes ma'am
newbie stay in formation
this is where you wanted me to flank
right
all right team let's take it this crouch
my controller is definitely too
sensitive
ma'am i am called up
see i'm flanking left as ordered
long time to reload
i wonder if you can level that up
get out of here
nice jump that bud
really went for it
okay now you're okay
oh
try to do takedown forgot that that is
on a timer which is a very strange
choice i wonder if you can do a you
could do melee without that
i'm really not sure oh okay so it goes
up the more kills you
get system
that just felt very janky i don't know
and i think the problem that i'm having
is
with the auto wave let's take it
is um sometimes it's extremely
aggressive and sometimes it feels like
it sort of
doesn't exist like up there i just
popped up there why would i not pop in
the middle
it's either very aggressive or
non-existent so it's a little bit hard
to like
pick which
you should go for but again it might
just mean that my sensitivity is off i
don't know
oh they're just too far away like maybe
i should have been pushing in
see yeah i don't know i don't know
i'm like okay i want to zoom in there
and it uh centered for some reason
i don't know
i'll figure it out
that too see right like i was like there
i expected it to center me on him
and it didn't
i do like the health system cool that
too right you see what i'm saying i
don't know
it just feels a bit odd
holding cover
perimeter's secure yeah that's probably
because of my flanking
now get in there and flush that son of a
[ __ ] okay
let's go
would love a shotgun
at this point to be honest
what does it take for a man to be able
to enjoy a quiet drink these days
mr nawali you're coming with me
you really think you have what it takes
to bring me in
i mean
yeah
he sucks so bad
oh boy hey where you [ __ ] going i
said you're coming with me
perhaps i don't respect your authority
then respect this i feel like i
recognize this voice
and it is very nice
holy [ __ ]
no you goddamn don't
all right uh chase this guy who is
way cooler than
you're
me
make it easy on yourself
can i join him
is that what i do maybe i do do that
maybe that's how i end up
as a saint rather than as a whatever
this dude's name is i can't find him
never mind get back here and regroup
we've got the bastard bottled up with
nowhere to run okay
we know he's in the saloon he can't stay
in there forever
what the [ __ ] thanks for the ride
i'll see you around
again
way cooler than me can i be that guy
we need air support now
stand down we don't got time for hero
[ __ ] don't worry got this
this is the that saints row opening that
we always have just absolutely bonkers
nice work
gwen we've got a problem hang on the
cavalry's coming
and i love the series for this stuff
like
sometimes it is fun to just play
something that is super silly and he's
not pretending to not be silly i'm not a
fan of
all the clippy dialogue and frankly if
there's a setting to turn it off i would
and i think that that's partly like a
fatigue so much of marvel is so
quippy these days um
so much media everybody's gotta have a
have a little jive and a little joke and
a little sarcastic bit and it's just
it's the saturation
um
everybody's deadpool is what's happened
it used to just be one deadpool and now
everyone is deadpool
um
but like i said
the silliness of this
the context of what is actually
happening here i i appreciate it
there's a place for it and that place is
saints row
um
i still don't know what the combat is
going to feel like in like what i assume
is going to be an open world but uh
to give you a negative um
in this segment
you know i said like it might go
floating and fun because of the jumping
and the rolling and it is very light
now that there's more of it um
and like
it's really a lot of it it's just me
killing a lot of people
and maybe it's because of the on rails
nature of this section yeah it doesn't
feel right and and i feel like maybe
it's something i want to play with mouse
and keyboard
which is not it just feels very i don't
know
it's really inaccurate and precise um
this is a lot of it it's an interesting
choice to have you do this much here
when it's probably not going to be as
strong as some of the like traversal
components of this game
i'll get the explosives i'm not even
seeing any explosives
where are their explosives sir
are you gonna die here explosives where
explosives explosives explosives i heard
they were explosives
am i even shooting at you
no
uh
i can't change my card boxes okay
which oh they're down there
my bad that's on me
you have more courage than brains
yeah i think there's a if in open world
context if you're like jumping around
like crazy the combat could feel fun but
in this
sort of scripted segment um
it's just sort of nothing
and yeah a little imprecise
am i
of course these are just first
impressions i've for 20 minutes
could be way off
nice
[Music]
it really does look like a
spaceship but i assume that's a military
ship and i'm just
military illiterate
you tried i'll give you that get your
hands in the air
i caught em
of course it's called that
oh boy
[Music]
okay
that's
now we ain't doing any of those
up shirts shirts
that looks nice to me do that
standard short colors
i like the blue
i guess i could do like a black jacket
like that but if i change the color
you can make custom colors that's neat
it's not dark enough
no
jacket uh underwear
okay
um
that's probably it lower
bottoms
oh you can't change it underwear
nope bottoms bottoms
the what the hell those are sick
sweatpants
dude
it's a no for me but those are awesome
we're gonna do these
i like them how they are
i guess you gotta put yourselves on
first
nice
don't like any of them i'm gonna go with
the boots
and make them dark
oh this just could be blue
nah lisa's gotta change sorry sorry
everybody
cool
done
yeah i don't think i will see what the
head stuff is but i don't think i want
to do any of it
off the face is gonna be glosses yeah
you know what
i've just made the most hipster man of
all time
i'm alright with it
let's go
yup
well you didn't die
he's hot though so not a bad start
jesus christ you're not gonna last that
was your pep talks need some work
scary at all this is for you performance
bonus
is this a joke
you uh you ribbing the rookie what were
you expecting there's supposed to be a
bonus based on exceptional performance
that's right and if you had performed
exceptionally you would have seen a
bonus oh come on can you really look me
in the eyes and say i didn't do well
i can look you in the eyes and say you
didn't do what you were told i saw a
better way and i took it and if you were
in charge it would have been an inspired
decision but you're not
i am
this is a warning
fall in line or find a new job it's a
pretty beloved trope the sort of
leader boss at the corporation really
hates the
rookie type vibe
i'm all right with it
style app oh that's neat you can just
change the way you look at any time
that's cool that's great
each weapon's signature ability visit
the weapon cache for details and track
progress on the weapon select wheel
are you on fire
dodge to put out the flames
shaders are still being optimized for
your hardware oh yeah again on pc i'm
playing with directx 12
because that's what it recommended
i will wait for optimization to complete
weather monitoring stations also serve
as launching pads for wingsuit flights
that's what i'm here for that's the kind
of thing i want
that's why it feels like that starting
section being as unreal as it is of
course it's a tutorial
um and having that much combat without
like the fun parts of sainsbury's combat
um probably sells it short i'm still
hopeful there's going to be some
some fun shootout stuff in here like the
the one that played like prototype
i guess we'll see
i will say so far i am not loving this
um
but maybe i'm just not the target
audience for this kind of game anymore
to be honest
um
i get it can you stop though like where
was the personality option for
not
douchebag
douchefag douchebag protagonist okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get it i get it i
get it again maybe it's for teenagers
i'm coming oh
the driving is pretty fun
am i getting points for doing this stuff
like it's forza horizon
did i get
once did the slam get is it giving me
something
xp it is okay
just occurred to me that i should
see if there's a licensed music
there we go off
sorry about that my bad i apologize i
apologize
you have three new messages
hey it's kev i'm making up a slamming
congratulatory brunch for when you get
home to celebrate your first day on the
job it's gonna be dope oh and it's
official i'm gonna be spinning at that
idols party i told you about so hope you
can come ttyl
hey there this is ugly
i thought you'd wanna know i i heard
back from the museum
they they went with someone else for the
junior art curator job so
looks like i'm still stuck with los
panteros
anyway i'm glad one of us had a good day
at least
see you
soon
is that his girlfriend this guy
managed to get a go
speaking of which um when you asked to
borrow my copy of your own boss i
assumed it was because you wanted to
read it not to level out the coffee
table so let's talk about that when you
get back can't wait to hear about all
the hr forms i'm sure you had to sign
oh i oh wait i'm living with a bunch of
people slash are they the saints
like i'm living in some sort of co-op
this is very ugly
this
is
okay
it is not a great open world but what
just hurt me did i get another cartoon
first
um but
maybe this isn't it
no interactivity that's all right it's
not really the point of this game
nothing okay
it happens it happens
oh i thought that was an elevator
my bad
oh everything smells amazing kev you
know what would make it smell even
better hey man if you want a 300 waffle
maker you can buy with the exposure the
idols pay you in don't expect us to chip
in i've told you before the idols are
trying to build a post-capitalist
society where money is not a concept
yeah great why don't you go run off and
join the commune i'm into showering are
you gonna help me get the waffle maker
or not as an investor i don't like
wasting money you're wearing a [ __ ]
bow tie
okay i will throw in 20 bucks for a
waffle maker
nina um good for 10. who helped you move
your forged paintings last month
fine 15.
what sort of waffle maker can i get for
35 bucks uh presumably one that makes
[ __ ] waffles
hey the wave slave is back
that's not how people react when i walk
in a room
now as far as hired killers go i'd give
him a seven
you look like he could use a mimosa
thanks eli seriously how was the job
yeah it's the murder business
the fundamentals don't change just the
uniform
i can tell you love it okay i don't have
to love it i have to pay my student
loans
i'm in
so i'm guessing that means the pay is
good that's supposed to be got stepped
on my bonus today dude what the [ __ ] i
played a little fast and loose on the
job and uh well i see i wasn't a fan you
gotta be kidding me swear to god this
lady walked right off the set of an 80s
action movie i was half expecting her to
call me rook and threaten to take my
badge
are we going to make rent we'll make
rent we just got to be a little more
creative
last time we got creative i got stabbed
three times hey it would have been four
times if nina and i hadn't shown up it
would have been zero times if you were
on time this is true look this is really
not a big deal we just knock off this
probably is going to be like the start
of the season
you have a job now you could actually
just take the loan
eli i don't do business with morally
bankrupt companies you worked for
marshall
brunch is a time for friends and mimosas
not debates on morality all right all
right
come on this is really [ __ ] good kev
thanks i was worried i added too much
pepper mm-hmm
no seriously this is perfect
the only way this could be better is if
you put on a [ __ ] shirt
dinner and a show baby
[Music]
okay okay he's done dishes are clean
let's go rob a payday loan place and you
know how we should celebrate afterwards
karaoke
yes
oh
i just wanted to explore a little bit
wardrobe i love the customization no
time for a nap won't let me
this interior is pretty cool you could
have some more stuff in here but that's
all right
nice little bathroom
mirrors don't work
be nice flush twice keep out
not going there
pretty cool place i live here
it's big
weapon cache huh
that's very
pretty okay same two guns that i've been
using
i guess i should take one i think i just
quit
um
yeah i'm not loving the characters to be
honest and again i think this is maybe
just a me thing like maybe i'm not the
audience for this game again it's very
quippy
we're boosting cars from down the street
it might be um just a younger
audience eli outgrown
the video game thinking acceleration is
going to matter more i'm not the target
market
just take that yellow one
i think i am i think 28 year old still
still counts
kev you case the place was it like 32
when they consider you not target market
i want some kick a dog so you know
[ __ ] that guy
see if i can cut through
nice
okay this car definitely feels very
different to the truck
this car feels awful to be honest
probably a bunch of different costs
you need to be
your own
boss
of your job of your happiness of your
life you don't make 15 an hour no you're
selling hours of your life away for 15
bucks a piece so what
there's a podcast he's listening to
there
very nice very nice that's right be your
own boss
one of these days i'm gonna get you to
listen to music in the car roger
mcgillicuddy speaks the music of my soul
you are a different kind of cat eli
what can i say the world is full of
uninteresting people and i'm not gonna
be one of them you got one of those for
me you really want one after last time i
am not the first person to accidentally
shoot a friend by dropping a loaded
yeah okay i don't need a gun
good call
showtime
so we're going to rob somewhere is
what's happening
so i made them watch while i broke their
dad's
[ __ ] walk away or the phrase dead end
job gets literal is that a good idea
while he's on the phone
not so sure we don't want your money
just his get out of here you done [ __ ]
up
i'm getting that a lot lately where's
the safe oh that's him you're lucky the
cops will get to you before my people
put the guy from the start if it's not
nice they've reused the
uh i can tell wrinkle art
safe's back here
this guy had his password be a bunch of
fives
he could have at least made his work for
it very good
same plan as last time eli kev pretend
traffic laws matter and get the money
home nina and i will split up and give
the cops the run around cool let me get
the mcgill again oh
something's gonna happen yeah yeah hold
on
[Applause]
it was just suspiciously easy
you know
i don't trust it
time to beat it before the cops show up
life is full of adversity and challenges
with oh [ __ ]
i'm monitoring the police scanner
they're just responding to the call
well did a good job there cops are now
enroute to the painting place
sounds like they're out of force
crap had time for a train
not really
should i
get around it
where did you even come from
[ __ ] guys i got cops on my ass nina
don't wait for me i gotta lose these
guys try sideswiping them it always
works for me just let them get alongside
you and then bam send them into a ditch
speed up
you need speed for a good side swipe
yeah yeah yeah it comes from full
side-to-side contact
okay
i let that car on fire
my mind
this is a
much more interesting system than um
then uh
having to like outrun them or whatever
eli and i made it home with the money
you ready for karaoke start warming up
those voices it's gonna be something to
balance is like how
persistent you want cops to be in these
kinds of
good god the man's either a monster or a
capitalist genius
new skill you leveled up and gained a
scale for use in combat this is funny
i'm using a playstation controller but
it's just given me a xbox prompt there
uh to activate the skill hold r1 and
press the assign button a skill
requires a full flow diamond
shine up like a health bar okay
um style skills
grab an enemy drop a grenade down their
pants and then throw them
this is the stuff that i do think is fun
um
but yeah stuff that i want from saints
row this yeah this world just does not
look good
it's not like they don't have a lot of
assets in here
it's not like it's super well it is
empty it's just
very flat
repeated animations
i don't know it could even be my
settings maybe i just the textures just
don't look right to me for some reason
what the [ __ ] did you [ __ ] do in my
getaway car ain't your car if it's on
our turf now you're gonna pay for
parking nice
i was expecting to just walk away and
steal something else to be honest
i need the clubs are coming y'all
i just feel like we should all be a
little bit more worried about the pups
and a little bit less worried
okay
those panteros scrapped my switch car
what big a problem the police picked up
that firefight at the junkyard they're
heading your way grab a bike and head
off the road
that's what i figured damn
sounds like no karaoke tonight every
[ __ ] time man i'm on my way there's a
trail that goes between the mesas i'll
meet you on the other side got it do i
want to know what happened to the
panthers who stripped your car
sorry nina
self-defense [ __ ] i didn't want that to
happen
let's hope sergio never finds out it was
us
i will say
so far i feel like this game is a little
bit rough around the edges
but i'm always okay with that i don't
mind rough around the edges um
but i'm actually just really not very
interested
um
nothing is like standing out as is very
cool and grabbing me i think like you
know the silly skills and stuff could
get really fun and i should say
i'm playing this a fair bit before the
uh review embargo reviews have not gone
out yet and this is obviously just the
first hour but i won't be able to play a
ton more
in time for that uh because my dad's in
town
and i think this game is going to go one
of two ways um it's either going to end
up after this first hour which is you
know a lot of tutorialization and
introduction
it's either going to end up being really
good like like uh oh my god you'll be
surprised by how good it gets or the
absolute opposite um
being
it's gonna be like
the first hour is showing you some of
the best parts of the game and then it's
gonna get really bad
i could see it
going either way be interested to see
the reviews down on the ground i am
worried it's gonna um
get less and less polished as time goes
on
and
you know the obnoxiousness of some of
the characters is again that's a
preference thing it's just not for me
but if this is them showing me like the
coolest stuff about the game as part of
the tutorial um yeah it's either gonna
get awesome as it unlocks
or this is it
you called for a ride
you said you didn't want to risk your
car
but i am not um
i'm not really into it thus far
but it's not like there's anything i'm
finding over all my bad or anything it's
just not not my style
i think i might have even felt that way
about previous saints row games because
i was a lot younger that's what i keep
thinking it's like maybe it's because
that went great
yeah okay
maybe i can
go back to running my old side hustles
for extra cash
didn't you just get a job
we'll figure it out
this town is full of opportunities
ah this is the actual city
cool
oh no it's the same place
just a different shot of it i guess
hey glad you made it home safe
just wanted to see what the garage would
have in it do karaoke again
also we'll get evicted nina said you
might go back to some of your old side
hustles i have some friends who might
need work done in your
area of expertise when you say friends
do you mean friends friends or special
friends all my friends are special
i'll put their info on your map i think
you really like them
all i can find as long as their money's
good
thanks captain come on go do the swing
suit one
because i'm the best at what i do that's
why
i talk to them
my car's running great
seem to enjoy our little billboard
adventure i just hope sergio never finds
out we pulled a job on pantero's turf
being here she's really not eating that
sandwich
no go for it
put it up to your mouth again
it happens man i feel like this is a
rushed rushed uh
not much left for groceries
four we're barely getting by
god i love this
do you you're not even eating it look
you literally have not even taken a bite
i
maybe what she means is more literal
than i'm taking it she loves it as in
she wants to kiss it
that's my bad i misunderstood i
misunderstood that's on me that's on me
did i tell you how badass that payday
loan getaway was because it was badass
you and nina damn you'll kick just as
much ass on the side hustles i know it
mm-hmm if you invest in us i promise you
you can't be disappointed
so i guess i gotta go just like get
money which um
it's probably part of my just interest
is not a cause i'm very interested in
i don't care about these people
it happens
let's take the truck
and where are we going nope map
map
probably to this one i want to try the
wingsuit for sure
all right
i wish i could articulate like maybe
once i've spent more time with it
and i like i never want to be mean about
things that people will obviously work
their ass and stuff on but um
this open world is not good
it is
very
dull
and um
flat and i don't know
just not feeling it
this seems like it'll be fun though so
let's give it a shot
shall be
i keep hurting myself by jumping out of
the car
okay my friend hello
how you been good i mean uh
great i hear you're now gainfully
employed
yeah but you know you could always use a
little extra on the side what are you up
to consulting got a big client in the
telecom sector telecom huh you
interested i don't really know much
about telecom no trust me this work is
right up your alley
still got your wingsuit yeah but i'm a
little rusty don't worry we'll go over
the basics yen i don't even know what
we're doing come on
let's go for a ride
okay
i'm excited to try this
the target is a set of receiver dishes
on the rooftops below the wing suit to
each target area and destroy the dishes
we have equipped you with some charges
for this purpose you ready ready as i'll
ever be let's do it
just your approach reduce speed and land
one more thing
you need to finish this job before time
runs out if we miss our window we gotta
scrub the whole operation
i messed that up real bad
you need more height
okay um
okay i just went too far down too fast i
think
yeah good
that's better
and then we could do this i think
uh okay
what are all of these oh okay got it um
so satchel charges uh
here
mess that up what did how do you want me
to do it i'm sure it gave me this
information and i just completely missed
it right
cool
one
two minutes left
and a three
who just yelled out of me
excuse me
to reach the next rooftop launch
yourself into the air with a weather
monitoring station
okay that's cool uh where is it
huh
okay let's go
really do keep getting stuck on stuff
i can use this tower to get a little
more height yeah let's roll
[Music]
there are only two right i think so
got a minute
wings to take down to damage your target
oh i have to fight somebody
uh how
i completely missed whatever that
control was
um then maybe i changed my gun i can't
get up there okay
oh shoot it
charge okay fine
and with time to spare nice work
these are still alive though telecom
business i messed up very competitive
seriously don't ask too many questions
just enjoy the paycheck
okay
oh well i just sit up here oh no
you do kinda that's cool
i mean it's definitely a super fun way
to traverse obviously um
great way to get around
an otherwise unfortunately uninteresting
city i wonder if i can call my car to me
somehow
[Laughter]
very good very good
um i think i might leave it there i'm
not sure exactly how long i've played
probably about an hour
um
yeah obviously this is the very
beginning of the game
too hard to judge but
i'm not feeling it thus far
i'm glad to see a lot of the like
creative silly stuff
um still take place despite not loving
some of the dialogue i think there's
probably like places this could go that
could end up being really good
or it's going to end up being really bad
i think that this is not going to be one
of those games that's like average down
the middle i think it's going to be one
of those two extremes it's going to
really really surprise people based on a
kind of like you know a little bit rough
opening it's like this opening's
terrible it's just like
again a lot of its preference i just
don't feel like it's for me but it's
also just it just punched my microphone
just feels a bit outdated
and then otherwise
it could go the complete opposite
direction and um
just get worse i'm not really sure i'm
sure this that some people will love it
um i'm unfortunately just not
super hot on it it happens of course
every now and then and i do have to give
a thank you
to
[Music]
i think it would be this humid game site
and epic probably the correct people to
thank for providing me with the code
they did provide me with a code um i did
not purchase the game and all that so
yeah thank you all for watching let me
know what you think the game is out um
by the time this video goes up it will
be out tomorrow see you guys next time